so remind you we're at the point where
we've defined this generalization of or
two functional extension of pure
Mankowski saw that it's it's powerful
and we prove it
and the proof will use the problem and
Kowski inequality which is why I left it
there yes you said it's a generalization
is it obvious yeah good nor I thought I
said extension but in fact you can prove
each from the other
I will only prove this from blue
Mankowski but this applied will also
give you if you got a way around it
takes more yeah so if we were to think
of you know think of a slightly weaker
statement here which says that the
volume is a log concave function instead
of saying that the one over air of the
volume is a concave function which is a
stronger statement then it's just a
special case of that where we where we
use these functions to be the section
volumes but it's nice that using the
dimension we can get a stronger
statement ok so ok so let's just prove
this and for that it's again going to be
an induction and but this time there are
no boxes the induction is on the
dimension n right so the first step is
for n equal to 1 given functions like
this we'd like to include this for
dimension one so the only sort of
concept idea is to say that look you can
think of the integral of a function as
also an integral over volumes of level
sets that's all if you think about
probabilities the expectation is also
the integral of the probability of your
bigger than something
so we'll just define the level set up so
we have these functions F G H for each
of them will define the level set H for
a non-negative number T to be the set of
points where the function value is at
least e and so the integral of H itself
is the integral of over T of the volume
of the level set of at some point where
T is high enough there's nothing left
and it goes to zero but I think it's
very no no yes yes the the the the whole
theorem is for non-negative functions
yeah okay not so good so now what can we
say about these level sets for the three
functions given the property the only
thing in the claim is that the level set
of this includes the convex combinations
of the corresponding level sets so
lambda L F of T plus 1 minus lambda L G
of T this is clear because if F is
bigger than T and G is bigger than T
this implies that H is bigger than T so
the level set contains this so we can
use now to bound the volume the
brennaman cost inequality in one
dimension and say what this is at least
lambda times volume of level set of F of
T right plus volume of levels of energy
or - now I'll separate integrals
and this is just again it's lambda
integral of F plus 1 minus lambda
integral of G which is certainly bigger
than
this is just a one-dimensional
okay that was good and now we don't need
the run winkowsky theorem anymore so you
usually run winkowsky for n equals to 1
yes and you said you can actually
realize this oh I'm not going to do that
proof phrase in India so so they read it
out we need the higher dimensional
version which will
so gentlemen that's a yes it's masla is
not sufficient you are doing every
single father yeah yeah I mean let's say
the function I don't know
this is H and I want to know it's
integral so what I'm doing is look this
is T so this is T it's a one-dimensional
function so we're looking at or if
you're counting like this right so
normally you do integral of H which is
this this is H of n H of X right and
instead you can count by horizontal
lines each horizontal line is exactly
the volume of LT right but you're
defining your H X is not able to achieve
on a trip matrix bigger or equal to this
everything a father all right did I
it's a way to the segment that fits
underneath the curve right yeah so so
it's it's it's still a set over here
this is that our domain is only our
domain is not the plane these are one
dimensional function so it could be you
know this whatever is the the largest
one the union of all the things above T
that's that's what we're counting as
yours okay so this is the one
dimensional version now to do it for
high dimension where are you going to
use induction right so I'm going to
define a projection to one dimension let
lower so for general n so suppose I have
XY in RN minus one now and alpha-beta
real numbers then all I want to do is
define this function H of gamma X
similarly for F and G to be the original
edge evaluated X comma gamma gamma is a
real number dimension Lord we're
thinking of them as n minus 1
dimensional functions where I fixed one
coordinate so if we do this and I choose
fix some lambda it's this and let's pick
gamma to be lambda alpha plus 1 - I'm
the beta this is just for convenience
I'm not writing that whole time and I'm
now going to look at H of you see this
this H of gamma at the convex
combination
and I want to say that it satisfies the
hypothesis of the of the theorem I know
and therefore by the induction
hypothesis we'll get this conclusion
that's a plan for every fixed alpha beta
and lambda this is a lower dimensional
function if it satisfies the hypothesis
of the free corporal Android theorem we
will use the National forces and argue
that the integrals satisfy the
conclusion that won't complete the proof
because we still need to worry about the
cameras but we'll do that ok so this is
just by definition H of lambda X plus 1
minus lambda Y comma lambda alpha plus 1
minus lambda theta which we know by
assumption on the function H is at least
f of X comma alpha to the lambda times G
of Y comma beta to the 1 minus lambda
which we can write it F alpha X to the
lambda times G beta Y to the 1 minus
lambda so for every fixed alpha beta and
lambda the function H gamma satisfies
satisfies this for all XY therefore by
the induction hypothesis for this is an
N minus 1 dimensional function we can
conclude that the integral of H gamma is
at least the integral of F alpha lambda
times the integral of G beta to the one
minus lon
so this hasn't finished everything
because we have fixed certain will fixed
for fixed alpha beta right n minus one
means that's what the induction
hypothesis is now we need to do one more
step it's going to use the
one-dimensional proof again so what
would the last step be you have to which
which one-dimensional function should we
apply it to again we need a hypothesis
that looks like this
and a conclusion that should now look
like the final conclusion in n
dimensions okay so we will just define
this integral itself right so in other
words define H of gamma to be the
integral of H gamma over all of our n
minus 1
so it's the end - for a fixed gamma if
there are n minus 1 dimensional now from
the from the conclusion from the
national airports as we get that edge of
lambda alpha plus 1 minus lambda beta is
at least capital F defined similarly of
alpha to the lambda times capital G beta
- 1 - language this is just what we got
now let's apply the one-dimensional
version to this to the functions capital
H capital F and capital G to conclude
that the integral over capital H over
just all real numbers is at least
interval over happiness lambda integral
over capital G to the 1 minus lambda but
this of course is the same as the
integral over R to the N of H itself
so these are all term by term equal
cut-and-paste
once but separately once I didn't use it
in the induction step I use the
induction hypothesis in the induction
step there was only it was only used
there
I mean of course in action a process is
implicitly she used two different air
induction one from n minus one or the
one yes yes so we have to combine it two
ways to get the final conclusion right
are we using the fact that this thing
hypothesis was for every lambda n zero
one or are we using it fixed lambda
lambda we can think of as fixed for the
entire proof so if I just know the
hypothesis for love
six lambda it still - yes
I mean look we're taking these
combinations here right no integrating
over RN it has to be you can ask to
contain the entire real line otherwise
the first part of the proof because
we're doing yeah yeah you might be able
to get some weak extension but not yeah
that's right
okay so that's the proof here we already
saw the applications and what we'll do
now is actually move to concentration
and will prove concentration using proc
Oberlander
so let me state the situation here I'll
leave the I'll leave this this part up
so this is the type of you know
illustrative classical theorem very says
suppose now I take a function this is
about concentration of functions around
their main or medium if I take a
function defined on the sphere real
valued function and the question I want
to ask is how well does it concentrate
near its mean so what is the probability
that f of X over drawn uniformly from
the sphere deviates from its expectation
by more than 70 all right this is the
this is the type of but I know which you
prefer this is the type of inequality
wonderful okay now in general this is
going to be current is anything but we
will assume that the function f is
Lipschitz
so if you change the argument by distant
in in Euclidean no will change by
distance one little change at most by L
so for example length on the sphere
changes only by by by with is one minute
so this is going to be now less than
twice each of the minus M T squared over
to give this exponential concentration
near the mean there's also an L square
outside when I prove I assume L is one
but let's
in particularly if F is the length
function then it
okay so want to prove something like
this now you can state this also for
other distributions like Y uniform over
the sphere this is a nice fact here
we'll see two different groups one proof
and one proof sketch let me state it
state a different version might be
weaker than what what one can prove
which is the following so let's take let
me take any subset of the sphere and the
sphere just RN sorry excuse me so that's
what makes it a different version so
we'll prove a similar statement not over
uniform over the sphere but over
gaussians that's the that's the version
that'll be more convenient to carry
around returns later and so so this is
some subset of space a and it'll be
interesting to mark out all of the all
of space that's close to this where the
distance is at most T to this
so a T will be the set of all points
where the distance to this subset is at
most
and gamma effects is just a Gaussian
density I'll drop the subscript n but in
n dimensions so standard now the the
statement is that the measure the the
Gaussian measure of a so the integral of
this over a times the integral over all
of our to the N of exponential in the
distance from X to a squared over four
times again here gamma so integrated
over the Gaussian measure is at most one
is the version we prove now there's
always this choice you know should I bow
to a dispersion by showing its
application first or disprove it first
good answer to this that there is no
eighty in this statement indeed why did
I define eighty good point so this is a
lemma and from this lemma the conclusion
will get about eighty is that the
measure of eighty of a times the measure
of a t compliment so what's far from the
set is at most e to the minus T squared
over four okay good so this is actually
the application this this this you'll be
happy with it's of independent
interesting the measure of any subset
times the measure of what's far from it
is small so if your set is large what's
farmer from it must be very small in
particularly if gamma is say a one-half
so you have a Gaussian measure 1/2 set
you go out distance T you're left with
only exponential in T squared okay why
does this follow from this look at this
integral here and let's only count this
integral over points that are in a t
compliment so the distance will be at
least T for each of them so you get e to
the T squared over four which I just
pull out and then what's left is just
the integral over 80 so this directly
implies
conclusion that's not actual
and that is nice
it's close ya up to constants right
right so the measure of the gaussian
measure so gamma of a set is just
integral over the set of the gaussian
manner so so let's prove this but this
is where the idea is and then and then
yeah so how do we prove this we're going
to use a couple anger we're just gonna
apply this theorem once no induction and
so I just have to choose the functions
carefully right F G H so let me give you
a hint F will map to this one G will map
to this one I mean the integrals
obviously this will be the conclusion
right so the conclusion will be about
integrals and H will map to this so what
should we define them to be f is f X
it's just going to be the indicator
function of the set a so it's 1 if
you're in the set a times the Gaussian
density so that the integral of f is
gamma G
is going to be this e to the distance X
a squared over 4 times the max and what
will each be Y and using the same
variable for F and G these are functions
I'm just defining functions now yeah the
end of the lecture I realize oh he was
right I should have used it but but
right now I don't think we're H of X
should be should be what just because he
means so at least with these settings if
we had the conclusion of the proper line
the theorem we would that is that is
simply this integral of H which is 1 is
at least integral of G which is this
quantity times integral of ok ok this ok
so now I go to I need to just show that
these functions satisfy the condition of
the of the of the tail so in fact we
don't need we're not we don't need it
for every lambda so the question we'll
just do lambda equals 1/2 okay so just
two lambda equals 1/2 so I want to show
that this is true for lambda equals 1/2
which means what that f at a point X
right x to the power one half times G at
a point Y to the power 1/2 is at most H
at the point X plus y over 2
that's it that's all we need to go okay
so let's verify that I know we know what
the right hand side is that's just
either minus X plus y over 2 lengths
squared over 2 okay I'll ignore the I'll
ignore the constant for the Gaussian
density it's the same everywhere and
then what about the left hand side f of
X to the 1/2 well let's see if X is not
in a then it's trivial because it's just
0 on the left so we can assume X is in
it and if X is in a then I can ignore
this indicator and I just get gum so you
get e to the minus x squared over 2
that's for the F contribution and then G
you get this which is how much now G of
Y right now Y the distance to a of Y is
certainly less than X minus y just
because X is one of the points in in a
hey that's the only bond we use so if I
use that bound here and put here an
upper bound on the left hand side I'm
going to get here e to the power of X
minus y squared over 4 right for the
distance bound and then times the
Gaussian density at Y which is y squared
over 2 and now amazingly this is any
question
take the squares okay so it's satisfied
oh yeah so so so very good question
we'll get to that towards the end for
example one could hope for proving this
for all log concave functions okay and
state what's true and what's what's
hopeful but for the sphere and the
Gaussian you get this Gaussian type
decay which is the best you can hope for
okay so that's concentration now we'll
move to an application of concentration
which is a whole area and so on this is
levy oh oh how do you from here to here
yeah you see Gaussian is vertically
symmetric so you can prove either one
from either one if you want one for the
for the yes exactly but you see if your
function with sorry I didn't prove it
for the ellipsis version but let me at
least just say a few words what did we
use here we used only this bound on this
distance if your function is L Lipschitz
then your distance is going to be at
most the function value divided by L so
the distance square will be function
value square divided by L square that's
it that's it you get the whole
conclusion you might the function
version yes
yes and then you know it turns out the
median yeah okay so next question is its
concentration I mean our concentration
these these direct key sections for
which I will
we don't need this anymore
dirt
okay
so just a bit of recap on these these
type of considerations so for this part
of the top will let's consider only
symmetric convex bodies right so we
assume that zero is in the body and if X
is in the body then so is minus X now
each such convex body defines a norm a
distance so this norm for point X with
respect to this called symmetric convex
body K it's just the smallest scaling of
the body that contains the point
so the minimum over all T such that X
belongs to TK T such that X belongs to
you yes yes so let's assume that this
has volume so convex body but anyway
okay now you know so we are suddenly
familiar with someone so if you talk
about this the corresponding body is
just the occlusion ball and if we talk
about this then it's real one ball and
if we talk about this then it's cubital
now and by this I mean the set of all X
where the summation of X I is less than
equal to VU so now also useful to
observe is that if you have this
relationship between norms like we have
X infinity is less than or equal to x2
always what this implies is that the
corresponding body here be infinity
right actually contains the Traverse
right because the bigger one is the 1
unit so to get the smaller one you you
only Franklin and then similarly this is
less than so
against v1 involve just a quick recap of
these things now theorem that's
classical and very useful in this field
is John's theorem about one of many
useful theorems which says that for any
such symmetric a symmetric convex or e a
there exists an ellipsoid
such that this is contained in K and
only a square root and scaling contains
K as we know is true for say x2 and x1
yes slightly let's drag over there okay
now if you didn't have symmetry just to
state this part of it you don't get the
square root
this is tight best possible and it's
easy to define the ellipsoid this
ellipsoid is just the maximum volume
ellipsoid in K and you click in volume
this this is going to give you this so
we have this routine relationship
between any two of these norms but it's
rooted and it's really it's real I mean
there are bodies that you really just
can't fit into the Euclidean ball unless
you scale the ball by route like thank
you I mean I won't go now
the consideration is the following ok I
can't fit the entire thing but I really
want to have something that looks like a
ball how large a section can you find
that looks like a ball so let me
so what's the largest dimension K so
that K has a section that's almost
Euclidean that's the question what is
the largest as I mentioned so this is
just integer K such that your convex
body K has trillion nearly Euclidean has
a make it precise nearly Euclidean
section of dimension so so that means
that there exists some subspace e so
that if I look at K intersect E so
that's the section the subspace it's
sandwiched between two balls and now we
mean Euclidean balls or let's where they
you are only changing the the factor by
an epsilon you pick the epsilon you pick
the epsilon and you would like to send
find a section that basically looks like
a ball of two epsilon so you've got some
complicated body but there is a section
here on this section you just have to
distort a little bit to catch the entire
thing yeah so in fact it's true for
balls what we did 46 the extremal bounds
that will prove that that that are true
are true for balls now now in fact in
general you can find an ellipsoid is
better than the ball but but as far as
the worst case is concerned
like yeah there's no question is for
given an epsilon what is the largest K
yes yeah so you want KN the function of
Epsilon
in fact now I'll state the theorem this
theorem is the this is a result of men a
lot of work in convex geometry and
function analysis influence the field
heavily but basically K is at least
epsilon squared constant epsilon squared
log 1 over epsilon times log n so this
we started with the body in k
dimensional space this is in RN so
there's a log n dimensional section
which is almost you clear
this is tight up to the this Login is
tight the function of epsilon is still
not right or not known to be done now in
fact we can say this so I'll just write
this as C of epsilon times log n
yes no no no subspace so we are going to
do it yeah that's not a single point
okay so now there is a nice generalized
way to state this this is the worst case
overall bodies you see for many parties
you expect you get build bigger sections
and so on there's a nice way to state
this more generally sometimes called the
generalized red ski which says lets me
look at the following quantity I'll
define M to be the expectation over just
the sphere of the length of X according
to your norm so if I pick a random unit
vector what is the length in your No
okay whatever it is and then and also as
you that your norm is no larger than
some factor B times the Euclidean it
should be something they might be rooted
please whatever we could be one if you
scale them under these circumstances you
have two parameters m and B this
dimension K is at least C of Epsilon now
keep that actually I can write down the
same function so let me write it down C
times epsilon squared over log 1 over
epsilon times n times M over B squared
it'll make sense in a minute because I'm
going to carry out some examples
alternatively this is just an
alternative version computations are
easier instead of defining this
expectation over the sphere will define
it over a Gaussian so let me define L to
be the expectation over a Gaussian of
the norm of X okay and again it's
cleaner to have the square into the
one-half but this is the same as up to a
constant the actual intervention makes
no difference upper constants this and
then if you do it like this then here
you get K is same function of epsilon
times L over B squared
the end goes away and that's no surprise
because in fact this L is up to a
constant square root n times n okay so
if you take an expectation over a
Gaussian or over a sphere these are
spherically symmetric thinks the only
thing you're worried about is how much
scaling you need to in each direction
and that's that's okay so this is this
is the this these are the versions of
the theorem now what does it say for
specific balls of interest in it and
then yeah we still have time to prove it
so let's take the two of the most common
examples I'll do here say the l1 ball
and we can do the computations at the
end there so if you have the l1 ball
what is the first question is what is B
right X one fits in square root n times
X to the L one length could be ten times
for a unit vector the other one length
could be could be ten times or 100 root
n for example so be root N and then the
next estimate is what is the L one
length square to the 1/2 for a random
unit vector I'm picking a random unit
vector on the sphere and asking what's
this length going to be about right they
are all linked so what is it going to be
Gaussian because it doesn't that's so I
picked a random right Gaussian
and I'm asking what is the length
squared but in one no okay
to the 1/2 fine
and this is about NY because we see this
is the summation of the coordinates here
you think of each coordinate it's it's
about a constant so you get constant
times n for just the length and square
to the one half affects the whole thing
only by a constant so the L in this case
is about n the bees root n so if you
substitute over there you get that the
section for this case is some constant
depending on epsilon times n so for the
L one ball take the L 1 ball there are
sections of constant times n dimension
which look just like you freedom balls
do you do the same computation with L
infinity this gives you only log n why
let's just do it if I do L infinity
second example L infinity then the
infinity norm is just less than the the
two norm so B is 1 B is 1 and now we're
just asking what is the expected maximum
coordinate right square for a unit
vector so I'll still write it as
infinity here squared to the one-half
where X is a Gaussian vector that's if I
pick a Gaussian vector the maximum
coordinate should be about root log in
and in fact this is true in expectations
take the max and take the expectation of
the max you still get longer
so if you put that in you get to login
and this in fact is the worst case not
just for L infinity but for all convex
bodies and the proof of that just goes
by showing that if you take any convex
body you can actually find an N over 2
dimensional L infinity ball at that and
then that has within it a log n
dimensional section yes so there are
general way to see what happens is HK
from same one like oh yeah is it getting
closer yeah yeah so so for a general
phenom here even the dimension here
instead of being so it was for for L
equal to 1 that this was N and here at
root log in in general it's n to the 2
over Q for a P P know if P is bigger
than P is bigger than 1 there must be an
expert will make sure I'm saying this
right times the same C over epsilon
factors but yeah it degrades
so between two it's still still some
function that fun the function of
epsilon in these proofs is the same and
we don't know if it's optimal as you go
between one and two I think it already
starts deteriorating a little bit but it
remains a polynomial in N it remains a
polynomial meant for any so this much is
true it remains the ball on will n for
any any p6p
ok so the proof ok how are we gonna do
this and how are you going to prove that
a convex body has a very large Euclidean
section what will prove is this version
here which says in terms of the expected
value of the length there is a large
section the dimension grows as some
function of epsilon times this this
expected length in your norm how are we
going to prove this which section should
we pick and we have to figure out a
section to pick right so which section
should be pick the hint is that we'll
use the previous theorem section yes so
we'll just pick a random section and so
the point is is so here's proof so we're
going to pick a random K dimensional
section we're going to choose the value
of K of course carefully
and so in fact the proof will conclude
that most sections have this property
now this dimension most sections you can
control the probability right so so it's
just a privacy argument you pick a
random section it contains this large
section and in case you're interested in
thank you very much an open problem it's
open to construct one so you know they
exist but to find one even for the four
for these special cases matching the
bound we know exists
okay so so so so why is this going to be
useful so our plan is this first you
take a fixed X okay no and now we'll
rotate it randomly apply random rotation
so so so now the distribution of X is
uniform okay so we've got a random
vector now this random vector will apply
a levee theorem here and say is the
probability that so we're gonna apply
levee to the function f of X equals the
norm of X in our norm so the probability
that this deviates from its expectation
which was the definition of M by more
than and we'll choose this threshold to
be epsilon in
less than e to the minus n epsilon
squared M Squared over two I'm going to
skip the L let's assume it's it's it's 1
Lipschitz so let's assume that we have
scaled K so that XK is less than or
equal to X so this we just get from levy
haven't done anything anything else this
is for a single point single random
point okay now we need to prove but this
is exactly what we need to prove but for
the entire section hey I will look what
is the same this is saying that the norm
of XK lies between 1 plus epsilon times
M its expectation and 1 minus epsilon
times m its expectation which are fixed
value so it's going to be like a ball
okay so the type properties like it's
it's it's within a Euclidean ball here
so that's what one point now we need to
argue for a K dimensional section
how are we going to argue for a K
dimensional section well we just use an
epsilon net okay for s to the K minus 1
what is here
so we will pick a net of points in such
that for every X on the sphere there
exists a Y in the net so that the
distance between x and y is less than
epsilon you might have to make epsilon
over 4 at the end but in some cases if
it is just a Euclidean Euclidean so by
our assumption that's a weaker thing yes
so such a net is used in many things
probably you've seen this a couple of
times in this in this workshop but the
size of the net in order to achieve this
lemma is only 1 plus 2 over epsilon to
the king
and the reason is you just pick a greedy
greedily picked in it start with the
point if there is a point that's not
close enough to the net so far take it
and and keep doing this till all points
have been covered now when you do this
you see that the your centers by the
child by the fact that they were being
picked really the balls of radius
epsilon over to around them must be
disjoint walls of radius epsilon over 2
must be disjoint because otherwise we
wouldn't have it was already inside a
ball of radius epsilon so around each
net point why if you take the epsilon
over 2 ball these are disjoint 4 over
all of them these balls are all
contained in the ball the the unit
sphere extended out by epsilon over 2 so
1 plus epsilon over 2 times therefore
the size of the net is at most the
volume of the outer thing which is 1
plus epsilon over 2 to the no not n here
K now to the K divided by volume of each
one which is now radius epsilon over 2
epsilon over 2 to the K which gives you
the 1 plus 2 over epsilon to the K but
this is just a packing argument
okay so that's the number now let's go
back here we want to combine this number
and do a union bound with this that will
that will be enough to conclude the
theorem I guess I should do it here
so combining these two these two parts
and then there's a third part which says
that if it's true for every point on the
net it's true for every point on the
sphere but that's just because you're
only moving by Epsilon
so your function can't change by more
than EPSA save on Lipschitz function so
that's that's the third part of usually
for any net argument but but certainly
here too
so now putting these two together the
probability that that this holds
conclusion holds
for all X in the net is at least one
minus for the size of the net times the
bound we have for each one so twice e to
the minus epsilon squared M Squared n
over 2 and n is this bound here to 1
plus 2 over epsilon to the K this is K
that's n
and so if I choose K to be as we said
some constant times epsilon squared over
law one over epsilon to take care of
this times n times M squared we we have
in our house a half probability this is
that's the corner of the segment is
probably sticker
now we have minutes and is going to talk
about isoparametric which is another way
to address things like levy and prove
more general concentration qualities the
part I didn't do about dirt ski is to
show you that the quantities M or L are
bounded for any convex body X I only
mentioned the outline that you can find
large at one section and then for that
one we can estimate explicitly otherwise
this complete okay I so very much so
isoparametric following general
consideration if you have a subset of
some well you know you what is the so
okay so here's here's it let you think
about it you know you have the
cake-cutting pump the usual cake-cutting
problem well you have a cake you want to
share it and so one person cuts the
other person chooses seems to be there
is you mean each wants to get the most
but then you know I so very much please
a different problem in fact to
illustrate it I so perimetry is the
avocado cutting okay I love avocados I'm
sure most of you do one of my top ten
discoveries of coming to the US but
please take one
you're welcome to keep it don't need it
yet so the point is this what is the
avocado cutting problem you want to eat
I don't know half here of a car 30% of
your of a car so you cut it you eat it
all you do with the rest you put it in
the fridge right and then you come back
the next day what happens
this you've got to get rid of fit
something so what would you like to do
make a cut off whatever fraction you
want 30% 40% that's you up to you but
that minimizes the surface area that's
the avocado grain problem so we're
talking about the avocado cutting
problem in high dimension that's it
that's our okay so how should you cut an
avocado in high dimension so as to
minimize the surface area and get the
fraction you care about okay it's very
very very practical foundations so here
is the the general problem suppose I
have some measure P in n dimensional
space okay function with boundary
integral and I'm interested in finding
the minimum over all subsets of the
boundary of this subset divided by the
smaller of the two so if for example
your measure was the uniform over convex
body for example and avocado you could
talk about some subset and ask what is
the ratio of the boundary to the volume
of this whichever is smaller okay now
what's the answer so for the two cases
we worked out for Levy's the answer is
very clean and classical for a sphere
you talk about subsets of the sphere any
subset or a Gaussian or draw a Gaussian
it's also classical and the answer is
half space it's just a half space no
matter what fraction you want there is a
half space that will give you the best
cut so in the case of a sphere it will
give you a lower dimensional sphere in
the case of a Gaussian it's just one
part of the cost that's optimal actually
this already lets us prove the strongest
version of levy you can imagine if you
prove this isoparametric inequality
because what is it saying suppose you
want to know what you have some subset a
and you want to know what is a distance
more than P from it well the way one way
to do it is let me choose
a to minimize the boundary and then I go
out distance T so I've captured as
little as possible near it and then
question is what's left but this is
exactly the band problem that we solved
the cap volume problem that we solved in
the beginning of this of this tutorial
and so it drops off as e to the minus T
squared n T squared over two in this
field e to the minus T squared over two
for a Gaussian so concentration follows
from isoparametric in this in a much
more general sense theorem but yes to
get anywhere we need to say something
about this measure right so the most
general version that we can talk about
is when P is low concave right which
capped so if P is La concave and the
function f is an Lipschitz
what can you say about the deviation of
this function from its mean or median
okay how what's the probability deviates
the subset doesn't have to be convex the
subset is arbitrary I see I picked
avocados because they of course good
pointer yeah okay okay it's only the set
that has been that you can argue but
okay so I want to state now a theorem
and a conjecture and stop there
the theorem is by Cullen Lobos and she
know it's and the conjecture is by the
same people
mommy's here so I believe he likes
avocados - but might not be the source
okay but the theorem is the following
take this setting here where peas lock
concave and you're asking about this
minimum possible value let's call this
value scipy the [ __ ] constant or
isoparametric constant of this
distribution proved is at side P is at
least absolute constant over square root
of the expected distance Square from the
me
okay so you have some distribution I can
pick point from the distribution and I
have a expected square disease this is
at least this another way to say it is
that if I were to consider sy bar P
which is the minimum over only
hyperplane cuts not all cuts but only
hyperplane cuts right then the point is
that this cannot be much lower than that
so sy p is at least 1 over root of these
this quantity here times sidebar P where
this is for hyperplane cuts
just humor me for one second I'll write
this theorem down and then we'll relate
everything then the conjecture says that
scipy is at least absolute constant x sy
p bar in other words up to a universal
constant factor for any low concave
function the best card which could be
really complicated is within a constant
of the best hyperplane cut just as
hyperplanes might not be optimal they
are optimal for gaussian sense fears but
in general they're not not even for the
triangle
she'll depending on the ratio but if you
talk about within universal constant
this constant might be - you don't know
there there is a there is always
hyperplane that approaches the best -
with the universal independent dimension
independent of the distribution
that's the conjecture understanding it
using the big the quantity which depends
on P is appearing in both cyber version
and the fastest version yes I party is a
constant in this case I have them both
here so here in the conjecture fine but
yeah yeah do a tight match okay to do
sites okay good so right here's the
selectmen let me state the state the
complete version
I mean a mu inversion this time so I
have a measure P let's assume that it's
a expectation over P of X is 0 and I'll
finish in two minutes I know I'm over
time and let's say that the covariance
matrix of X over P is a that's our four
valence matrix then the theorem says
that psy P is at least constant divided
by square root of the trace of a
that's it there's no happy bar sigh bar
P and this is just an exercise is always
at least constant over square root of
the largest eigenvalue of a this is the
sum of eigenvalues or lies this is just
ER
ok so you get this ratio here theorem
says that site P itself is at least
constant over square root of largest
eigenvalue there is a relatively recent
improvement joint work with me
building on a technique of Ron and Eldon
which says that instead of trace of a we
can say that scipy is at least constant
over so this is the sum of the
eigenvalues you can say sum of the
squares of the eigenvalues to the power
one fourth which gives asymptotic
improvements because when you have let's
say the covariance matrix equal to the
identity when a is identity then the kls
theorem says constant over root n the
careless conjecture says constant and
this theorem says constant over N to the
1/4
so what we know today is that the best
you can do is better than high protein
cut by at most n to the 1/4 but it could
be that the whole thing is true and if
this conjecture is true for
concentration you get that the
probability that F deviates from its
expectation by more than say T drops off
as e to the minus T where the T here and
then Lipschitz as usual and constantly
what really happens is that that
parameter the karelis conjecture
constant just goes straight in here so
right now we have it with n to the 1/4
but maybe this is completely unnecessary
I should probably stop here honestly
yeah way over time
we do this oh you can eat it it's yours
sir if you got nothing from the lecture
to bring food into the auditorium right
learning tool